foreign
what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here today as all you guys are aware
there's been a writer strike going on and as of
last week the SAG strike is now happening there's
some great videos that you guys can watch about it
I mean I myself just did a podcast with Paul heavy
spoilers or podcasts Across the Universe where we
gave our very much impassioned discussion about
the sex strike we are of course in support of the
SAT strike if you want to watch it's like a great
like breakdown of it the best one that I've seen
I would have to say is Dan Merle's video of really
breaking down uh exactly what the SAG strike is
completely all about it's really well informed
it's an entertaining one as well what I wanted to
focus on today specifically is what influencers
can and cannot do in regards to the sex strike of
what would be deemed okay and acceptable and what
would ultimately be a violation going against the
SAG strike order when you go online you're going
to see like a whole bunch of discourse about what
is okay and what is not okay are people allowed
to review Barbie and Oppenheimer can they do this
can they do that like what's all right what isn't
all right and so what I've done uh you know I
spent a long time on this I have cross-referenced
with the Stag strike order that was sent out the
FAQ about influencers that was sent out and then
a little bit ago variety they just published an
article where they've laid out even more rules I
made it even clearer of what you can and cannot
do and I also did speak with a publicist isn't
really concerned about their clients they wanted
to understand a lot of the rules and on top of
that too I have been talking with people who are
members of Sac who are also on press there's just
a lot of different notes and all compiliters so
this is the best that I could do I just wanted to
give a really straight forward kind of reference
breakdown sheet for you all of everything I was
able to gather between three categories here the
first category I'm going to talk about if you are
a union influencer if you are sag and you
are also an influencer and also if you're
a non-union influencer and the third thing I want
to talk about is with all this information of how
the real rejects wishes to proceed moving forward
so with that in mind if you guys can leave a like
on this video that'd be very much appreciated I'm
going to be incredibly direct with you all I know
normally I go off the dome but I just kind of
made a bunch of notes and I just wanted to make
something that could be a solid reference for
everyone because yes this would be good if you
are an influencer and you are concerned about this
secondly there's a lot of viewers out there who
want to make sure that their influencers are
you know following the guidelines here and I
know some won't care at all but for those who do
care this is for you lastly at the same time if
I happen to get anything blatantly wrong please
do the YouTube thing be comment police because
some stuff is not entirely clear and that's why
variety even had to put out that article where
sag had to elaborate even more and there's some
stuff that does require further elaboration but
based off my research this is the best I could
find but like I said there's anything I get like
definite like definitive like no that's completely
wrong I want you to correct me and I want that
comment to be highlighted that way people will
see the right thing alrighty so let's get to it
if you are an influencer here's what you can do
you can do commercial works this is brand deals
that align with sag after rules so essentially you
can work with Brands you usually collaborate with
as long as you follow the Union's rules however
if a brand deal involves a company currently on
strike contact influencer at sagafter.org to make
sure you're on the right track okay and here's an
important one as well because if you happen to see
an influencer promoting a product that you know
is from one of these struck companies one thing
you want to make sure of if it's something that
is a concern of you is did they get this deal
before the strike officially happened because
they can carry out existing contracts with
struck companies but they can't take on new
ones so basically if you've agreed to promote a
struck company before the strike began stick to
your word but don't start new projects with these
companies during the strike actually we're in in
that boat right now I just remembered is that we
have a uh three brand deals I want to say that uh
we have already submitted for that we've already
got the you know the edit done for them now it's
just been like okay we're waiting for you to go
yep post it that was a couple weeks ago and as
many YouTubers will tell you some brands are they
take like six weeks to finally be like all right
but we're already in contract with them but during
the strike we've already told our brand manager
that for the remainder of the strike while it's
happening to not accept anything that comes in
from a studio so you want to hold me accountable
I I believe it's three that we've got you can keep
creating and posting content as long as it's
not about the work on strike continue sharing
your usual content just avoid discussing the
companies or work on strike all right so here's
what you can't do take on new jobs to promote
struck companies simply put avoid starting new
collaborations that involve promoting content from
companies currently on strike what you'll discover
here is most of this is going to boil down to
just don't promote [__] for them I know that
part gets a little bit like wait but what is does
that mean promoted it'll go into more details you
can't post about any work on strike whether you're
paid or not this means avoiding the promotion of
struck company's content on your social platforms
cannot participate in events like Comic-Con to
promote struck companies or work you can go
to these events but don't engage in promoting
The Struck work there real rejects we do have a
Comic-Con panel coming up that we did agree to
uh a long time ago we got to do that but it's not
for like a studio or anything of that sort either
way well it should just be business as usual this
part's the one that I see a lot of debate over
you cannot take part in activities like cosplay
of characters from struck work basically avoid
promoting struck companies through your character
portrayal so yeah that kind of takes takes a lot
of Cosplay out the window at that point from the
sound of it it sounds like if you are sagged they
really want you to not be doing cosplay if you're
non-union that they're more like sure go ahead
um but yeah either way I mean I still think it's
a an interesting one to lay down so then the
big question that was asked here on the FAQ
page was how does this apply to me if I'm a
non-union influencer any non-member seeking future
membership in Sag after who performs covered work
or services for a struck company during the strike
will not be emitted into membership in Sag after
all right so what does this mean exactly first
off really if you're not interested in any of the
SAG after business and you are an influencer you
can really do whatever you want it's your choice
so I'm speaking of those who are not Union who
still care to not break violation still want to
make sure that they can one day be eligible
to be sagged and if you're not an influencer
I'm also speaking to those who care to see if
the influencers they follow are following the
rules laid out a lot of it comes down to is if
you want to make sure you can still be part of
sag in the future but the thing that they specify
that you cannot do is do covered work for a struck
company if you're planning to join sag after
essentially if you hope to join the union one day
avoid working with struck companies so what does
cover work entail what does that actually mean
especially based off of their guidelines without
me just giving you essentially a whole bunch of
exposition here mainly what it comes down to is
avoid any and all promotional work when it comes
to working with Studios which usually involves
a financial transaction of some sort an official
agreement whether that be hey you know come attend
this influencer event where we're going to give
you free food and drinks and all you got to do
is post about our movie just some kind of mutual
understanding that you are actively working to
help promote the movie and yes of course like
don't don't act in anything you know like you know
the obvious stuff of not to do like don't don't
do any of that stuff like auditions for struck
projects and all that so yeah don't do any of that
but in terms of the promotional work that's that's
the main thing you got to be concerned about
because here's where people were often getting
confused on but do reviews quantify as that I'll
go into that in just a tiny bit so essentially
cover worked what it could be promoting a
struck company's content attending events to
promote a truck company like a movie premiere
participating in a campaign that indirectly
promotes a struck company and while they made
it crystal clear on some things here there is one
statement that they did put out that I'm glad they
did because some stuff does perhaps require some
more clarification because when asked what happens
if I break the strike rules the answer was if you
do it inadvertently someone will probably tap you
on the shoulder and remind you not to do it again
but the union absolutely has the power to enforce
its strike rules penalties may include censor
reprimand fine suspension and or expulsion if
you are not a member and perform struck work
you will be barred from joining the Union in
the future well that ends on a really like dark
note originally it was sounded like if you do
anything wrongly wrong you're going to be barred
permanently Fine Lines a lot of us influencers
everyone a lot of people are just trying their
best right now a lot of people who really do care
about her are trying their best and at the end of
the day if you do believe you're doing you know
what is within your writing is not a violation of
the strike rules I don't think you have to worry
about you know being banished to hell right away
okay now let's talk about uh real rejects because
our Channel essentially does like the main variety
of what other channels also also do even if it's
not like specifically like hey an Easter egg
breakdown or whatever it's still essentially
in in the similar categories it's all right like a
lot of people know I'm not the biggest fan of the
word influence I have nothing against influencers
whatsoever I'm one of them but I just don't really
like that word too much but at the end of the day
I am that and that's my category now our other
category is entertainment journalist that's why
we've been on pressless for so many years that's
what we are qualified as on the on the Press
list sometimes there's like an influencer press
list and then there's a entertainment journalist
press listen and we're always on the entertainment
journalist press list because at the end of the
day all of our content is created for purposes of
commentary analysis and or review so if you're one
of those channels as well where your content is
created for those purposes then I feel like this
will all be applicable for you so and look at the
categories here let's talk about movie reviews
so reviews they serve as a journalistic role
the whole point is to provide impartial critique
rather than promotion like the whole point is to
offer analysis to help viewers you know choose
what to watch or encourage or discourage urge
you know however it may be what's really essential
though is that reviewers don't accept payment for
positive reviews I mean I don't feel like you
should ever do that just in general especially
now don't expect payment for positive reviews
from struck companies as this would completely
enter that promotional territory and the Variety
article they cleared this up like Crystal when
asked I'm a film critic can I review movies the
answer was absolutely critics are not on strike
and are not obligated to stop reviewing movies
or TV shows that clears that up follow it up with
I'm an entertainment journalist can I cover movies
and TV yes entertainment journalists whether they
belong to a union or not are not on strike even
those broadcast journalists who are represented by
sag-aftra are not affected as the strike relates
only to the TV theatrical contract so there you
have it reviews are okay there was a question
in there that was starting to confuse some
people that was about influencers can influencers
promote a movie again that question was about can
influencers promote category of covered Services
recovered work which obviously that right there
that's the big No-No when researching into movie
news reporting movie news should be acceptable
because the whole point is it aims to inform the
public right not to promote struck companies so
again impartial news coverage that does in favor
struck companies doesn't violate strike rules all
right trailer reactions and reviews these
are usually seen as commentary or critique
that generally falls under fair use laws despite
whatever them music companies are always fighting
with on those trailers you're always doing like
the whole point is to help encourage or help
viewers to understand what to expect from a film
or a show and they don't inherently promote struck
companies so that should be okay movie and TV show
reactions so if you're doing episode reactions or
a movie reaction of course this is all like really
much you know edited cut up that always leads into
a full-on review the main purpose of a reaction
video is for entertainment commentary to uh spur
a conversation about the content and of course the
movie and TV show are always to support the other
half of the video review to the analysis section
as long as these reactions aren't endorsing or
promoting a struck company they're generally
acceptable and then from everything I can see
and read up on as what's been laid out here in the
Variety article and knowing that there are a sag
members in the Press who have been going to press
screenings you're an entertainment journalist you
can still review movies cover movies and attend
press screenings initially I was like I feel
like we're not supposed to I don't I I don't
know like I was on the fence about Oppenheimer
for example but from the updates and from talking
with other people who are actually sag seems like
that's actually okay because even in a strike
situation your attendance at a press screening
doesn't equate to promoting The Struck company or
its product the whole point is to be there as an
impartial Observer delivering information analysis
or critique the usual to the public and it's
crucial to maintain this distance and objectivity
I think even if there's not a strike that's
crucial to avoid any appearance of endorsement
or promotion as a strike what it mostly targets
is promotional work typically covered under sag
after so from what I can see and this is like you
know uh more than just like conversations it's
been it has been a lot of research from what I
can see we can proceed as normal if we just
you know we can't do any promotional things
we can't be like hey we want to use your footage
uh that we saw you do of something and use it in
our advertisement can't say any agree to any of
that you can't do anything like hey we want to
send you this Spider-Man habit at the end of the
day that's going to get approved from Disney that
can't do that so you know there's a whole bunch
of things that basically boil down to just don't
do promotional work for them and obviously
don't do any gigs or auditions or anything
that relate to participating in one of the truck
companies movies or whatever so of course we are
maintaining an awareness and we do care to be
supportive because frankly the fact of how the
amptp is treating our writers and actors is a
total [__] uh deep dive a lot into it on that
podcast I did with Paul it's not what this video
is about but yeah if you want to hear more about
my opinions on that please go ahead and check
that out and the day I firmly believe that what
they're fighting for is exactly what they should
be fighting for so if we do anything that truly
steps out of bounds we'll do our best to correct
it anyway hope this information helps you just let
me know if it does uh leave their thoughts Down
Below on how you've been feeling about the stack
strike and all that learn that I'll talk with
you guys soon thank you so much for being here